president biden has begun his sales
pitch for the stimulus
the first stop in the help is here tour
chester pennsylvania also tonight we now
know when the president will hold his
first
solo news conference here's white house
correspondent peter ducey good evening
peter
good evening brett and anytime the full
press corps has access to the president
and he hears
something shouted he doesn't like he can
just walk away but that's all going to
change
next thursday when for the first time he
will
face reporters with 64 days worth of
things to ask
in a formal setting president biden is
finally
taking questions but not at a formal
press conference
till next thursday instead from the
owners of smith's flooring in chester
pennsylvania
and he's making trips like this you
really made it work
and i think you should be aware more
help is on the way for real hoping to
avoid
this in the midterms i'm not
recommending for every future president
that they take a shellacking like they
like i did last night the white house
sees big political upside for them in
this package a cnn poll finds
is favored by 61 percent of americans
and
is already signed into law it's not
selling it it's literally
letting people know their rights right
it's it's kind of like you um
you buy a product you've already been
sold on the product but you need some
directions on the box usually but
republicans are buying air time arguing
the bill isn't relief it's a progressive
wish list with what they call a 350
billion dollar
blue state bailout 600 million dollars
for san francisco
and 86 billion dollars for a pension
bailout that predates covet 19.
the tax and spend democrats are back
president biden has just signed into law
a 1.9
trillion dollar spending bill and now
the white house and president biden are
talking about
raising taxes so far the white house
travel itinerary features a lot of
swing states pennsylvania and georgia
for the president
nevada and colorado for the vp we'll be
certainly going to some
redder states i wouldn't overread into
it in that way but as parties strategize
ahead of the midterms
the president is practical about the
potential pitfalls of a bill
that only got through congress with
democratic support it's not like it
passed with 100 votes you know what i
mean
it was close and so the whole point of
today's trip
is to try to make the stimulus package a
winner for the democrats who voted for
it
and a loser for the republicans who
voted against it and today's
stops in pennsylvania were close enough
to the delaware state line that the
president is going to overnight
at his residence here in wilmington
brett
peter ducey in wilmington peter thanks
moderna
is beginning a